j'ouvre le second débat de ce sens
public consacré à la guerre qui continue
au Proche Orient le secrétaire d'État
américain Anthony blinken é en tourné
dans la région pour éviter tenter
d'éviter une escalade régionale avant de
de débattre autour de ce risque de cette
guerre qui rentre dans son 3e mois je
vous propose un reportage tourné il y a
quelques jours en Israël dans l'un des
kibuts attaqués par le Hamas le 7
octobre 3 mois plus tard les habitants
toujours sous le choc Aure
vetaz dans le kibut de karaza le temps
s'est arrêté le matin du 7 octobre les
tentes et les décorations de la fête de
souscôte sont encore en place comme les
vélos des enfants mais leurs rire ont
disparu remplacé par le silence et les
bombardements car nous sommes ici à 4 km
de la bande de Gaza actuellement pilonné
par tsal une situation géographique qui
en fait l'un des kibuts les plus
durement touchés par les exactions du
Hamas quand vous voyez un comme celui-ci
avec un point de dent sur une habitation
ça veut dire qu'on a trouvé un ou
plusieurs corps et les inscriptions
comme celle-ci il y en a sur de très
nombreuses maisons ici 63 personnes ont
été assassinées 17 autres kidnappé des
histoires insoutenables que les
sénateurs français veulent tout de même
entendre pour comprendre et rapporter
face à eux le commandant d'UDI Glasman
il est à la tête de l'une des unités qui
travaille à identifier les corps sa
mission continue même 3 mois plus tard
il y a des gens qui ont été brûlés vif
dans leur maison une fois nous avons cru
qu'il n'y avait qu'un corps à identifié
mais il y en avait en fait trois
entreemêlés un père qui avait enlacé ses
enfants avant de mourir ce
silence les oiseaux qu'on entend
seulement c'est les maisons qui sont
brûlées et on imagine très bien la
tragédie qui s'est déroulé ici et puis
il y a la douleur dans la douleur comme
dans la partie des jeunes du kibuts ou
la photo de Yota
28 ans flotte encore devant sa
maison il a été kidnappé par le Hamas et
il fait partie des trois otages qui ont
réussi à se libérer mais malheureusement
ils ont été pris pour des terroristes
par nos soldats et abattus ça aurait pu
être un grand moment de joie mais ça a
été l'un des pires pour Israël des
visites comme celle-ci sont primordiales
pour garder le soutien de ses alliés ça
ne sera pas sûr ici tant que nous
n'aurons pas éliminé le Hamas
militairement et politiquement nous
devons finir le travail et je veux
remercier le Sénat français pour son
soutien
aujourd'hui après
avoir
marché marché dans dans ce Kib il y a
quelque chose d'extraordinairement
émouvant pour nous dont nous avons le
devoir de porter témoignage notre
souhait vraiment c'est que la paix
revienne et que les enfants un jour
puissent rejouer
mais comme un espoir une première
famille a déjà tenu à revenir Charal et
sa femme ayalite malgré le danger et les
souvenirs d'horreur mais pas question
d'oublier pour autant la douloureuse
date du 7 octobre reste gravé dans leur
chair voilà reportage réalisé juste
avant les vacances de Noël à l'occasion
vous l'avez vu de de cette visite
sénatoriale délégation
sénatoriale en Israël et et au Proche
Orient le traumatisme de de la guerre le
le risque d'escalade régionale mais
aussi Israël l'État d'Israël convoqué
dans la justice internationale voilà
trois grands thèmes dont on va débattre
tout de suite avec Simone ronand
menzaken bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes directrice Europe de l'American
Jewish commite Jérôme clge bonsoir
bonsoir et bienvenue enseignant
prospective et stratégie à à sciencep
Paris auteur de ce livre la prospective
stratégique aux éditions Herman on a
également avec nous en en duplexe depuis
Tel Aviv Julien baloule spécialiste de
la société israélienne et ancien
journaliste ancien porte-parole
également des réservistes de tsal
bonsoir et bienvenue à Julien Bou
évidemment Mathieu croissondo est rester
à mes côtés on va parler des des
traumatismes pour commencer de la
société israélienne mais aussi de des
des Palestiniens Simon ronant Benzaken
ce le traumatisme de la société Israël
on l'a vu dans le reportage à quel point
est-il toujours aussi vif 3 mois après
très et je pense que Julien Bou va
pouvoir nous en éclairer encore
davantage euh moi j'y suis allée euh il
y a quelques semaines euh ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que aujourd'hui on est
le 8 janvier euh pour les israélien on
est toujours le 7 octobre
euh je vous au moment où j'y étais la
vie commençait à reprendre un peu
c'est-à-dire vous alliez avoir des
restaurants qui ont commencé à ouvrir
des cafés et cetera mais les gens sont
constamment euh scotchés à leur télé à
leur téléphone euh la question des
otages est omniprésente dans la société
israélienne eu vous avez tous les jours
quasiment des des des soldats qui sont
tués à Gaza donc c'est une une armée du
peuple donc forcément les gens sont
toujours conscients de ça et ensuite
vous avez bien évidemment les
témoignages vous avez pas un jour sans
une autre horreur en fait qui que que
vous allez découvrir sur les violences
sexuelles sur les tortures sur les
tortures psychologiqu euh là aujourd'hui
encore on a découvert des des nouvelles
images de quatre jees femme détenue à
Gaza avec des des
visages voilà tu méfi et donc c'est
omniprésent dans la société
israélienne et donc le 7 octobre est
comme un tatouage dans les cœurs de de
chaque israélien je pense alors
justement je me tourne vers Julien
baloule pour avoir tout de suite votre
avis là-dessus peut-on comprendre le la
politique du cabinet de guerre et la
durée on se pose jusqu'à quand cette
guerre là durée de l'intervention de la
haripost à Gaza sans prendre conscience
de de ce traumatisme à vif en fait je
crois que les il faut comprendre qu'il y
a déjà eu plusieurs cyles de violence
dans le passé que les Israéliens
clairement cette fois veulent que ça
serve à quelque chose c'est-à-dire que
on a vu si on prend l'historique de ces
dernières années il y avait des cycles
de violence qui étaient de plus en plus
rapprochés dans le temps donc il y avait
un sentiment que finalement ça servait à
rien ce qui se passait des gens mourent
des soldats mouris des Palestiniens
mourent du sang tombé du sang coulé pour
finalement vu que la situation sur le
terrain revenait au jours d'avant sans
changement et là les Israéliens veulent
que ça serve à quelque chose ils disent
ok on est prêt à faire un sacrifice on
est prêt à risquer la vie de nos enfants
mais pourquoi ça sert à quelque chose ça
sert à quelque chose c'estut dire quoi
c'està dire que le Hamas ne soit plus en
capacité de de menacer la vie des
Israéliens c'est c'est éidemment de ça
dont on parle il y a aussi le fait que
il faut le retour des des otages et je
pense que vraiment euh la la vraie
différence entre cette guerre et les
précédentes opérations c'est que les
Isra australiens sont prêts à attendre
et à payer le prix et et attendre le
temps qu'il faut pour qu'il y ait des
résultats on est à plus de 3 mois de
guerre je sais pas si vous rendez compte
ce que ça veut dire pour un pays de 9
millions d'habitants moi par exemple
l'entreprise highch où je travaille on
était au début de de de de la guerre à
plus de 25 % des employés qui étaient
pas là un/4 de la main d're qui était
pas là sur un pays de 9 millions
d'habitants quand il y a des centaines
de milliers de personnes qui sont
rappelées par l'armée pas forcément pour
à Gazin ça peut être aussi pour aller
s'occuper des écoles pour aider les
enfants pour faire la logistique pour
apporte mais on quitte son entreprise ça
désorganise l'économie il y a toutes les
compagnies aériennes étrangères qui ont
quitté le pays depuis le 7 octobre il y
a plus que Hal ça veut dire l'économie
prend un coût énorme le le le le marché
du travail est désorganisé il y a des
dizaines et des dizaines de milliers
d'Israéliens qui n'habitent plus chez
eux actuellement au Nord et au Sud qui
ont été déplacés qui ont été relagés
relogés dans des hôtels depuis déjà plus
de 3 mois et le pays tient malgré tout
parce que les Israéliens sont prêts à
faire ce sacrifice encore une fois si ça
sert à quelque chose si ça sert à rien
il y aura une grosse colère alors
j'accueille sur ce plateau B Nabli
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes professeur
de droit lupec Paris 12 consultant
international au cabinet lisias
partnaire c'est vous publiier relations
internationales droit théorie et
pratique édition pédon on on on démarre
ce débat il y aura plusieurs chapitres
hein on va parler notamment de la
convocation d'Israël cette requête menée
par l'Afrique du Sud devant la justice
internationale enfin il y a beaucoup de
thèmes là on est sur le traumatisme le
traumatisme subi par les Israéliens on
va parler juste après du traumatisme des
Palestiniens est-ce que on sous-estime
encore aujourd'hui le traumatisme
israélien quand on analyse la la reposte
de tel euh c'est toujours difficile de
mesurer un traumatisme par définition à
l'échelle individuelle et encore plus je
pense à l'échelle collective mais à
l'échelle collective c'est il y a une
dimension politique que ça engage ça
engage la responsabilité de ceux qui
vont essayer d'incarner ben finalement
pas ce traumatisme mais du moins la
traduction politique de l'État du pays
et donc effectivement on peut
s'interroger sur la relation entre
l'état psychologique collectif du pays
et de l'autre la stratégie militaire et
le discours politique qui est tenu ce
qu'on peut dire au jour d'aujourd'hui
c'est qu'à priori il y a quand même
encore un un soutien assez assez fort
derrière à la fois la stratégie
militaire menée à à Gaza et et le
discours de fermeté du Premier ministre
netaniahou avec en même temps si j'ose
dire un discours critique aussi
vis-à-vis de ce Premier ministre qui est
contesté en tant que tel ça personne ne
fait pas l'unanimité c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire donc il y a cette
tension voir cette ambivalence entre la
société israélienne et et ceux qui qui
la représentent ses dirigeants oui pour
l'instant euh ce ce on peut dire que
c'est encore en en phase c'est ce que je
comprends euh on va y revenir sur la
popularité et la la mise en cause éal
Yanou dans dans dans un instant il y a
eu quand même Jérôme kche la la question
de l'après qui a été évoquée récemment
notamment par le le ministre israélien
de la de la défense avec un un plan avec
beaucoup de zones de de de de flou et
d'incertitude mais qu'est-ce que ça dit
quand même cette communication bah ça
dit vraisemblablement comme vous le
dites qu'il y a beaucoup de zones de
flou et d'incertitude donc c'est plutôt
la temporalité qui a à retenir
c'est-à-dire que là les Israéliens
communiquent avant on communiquit avant
puisque c'était le 4 janvier ce à quoi
vous faites référence avant la tournée
au Moyen-Orient de d'Anthony blincen
voilà et ce que ça dit c'est qu'il y a
une volonté semble-t-il de R assurer ou
d'apaiser un petit peu l'opinion
publique internationale notamment qui
commence à être véritablement hostile en
fait hein pour dire les choses telles
qu'elles sont à la guerre que Israël
mène sur la bande de Gaza et non pas
contre Gaza je crois que c'est important
de de souligner ça ce plan en quatre
points rapidement euh absence absence de
la solution à deux États qui reste quand
même le point de mire de cette
après-guerre voulu par par la communauté
internationale et rappelé par Anthony
blinken un point sur l'occupation parce
que c'était la grande préoccupation si
j'ose dire de la communauté
internationale c'est qu'il n'y ait pas
de retour de Colon israélien sur la
bande de Gaza et là pour faire pour
faire bonne mesure avec ce qu'a dit le
ministre bengvir de la Sécurité
Nationale qui lui souhaitait le retour
d'une occupation sur la bande de Gaza le
ministre de la Défense israélien a bien
dit qu'il n'y aurait pas d'occupation et
le un des points important c'est le 3è
s'agissant d'une Task Force
internationale pour la réhabilitation de
Gaza avec les États-Unis ses partenaires
européens et évidemment Israël afin de
montrer comment on pourrait avoir
retrouveré le contrôle finalement de la
bande de Gaza sans pour autant qu'il a
d'occupation israélienne donc c'est ça
que ça dit en fait c'est une volonté
surtout de rassurer à un moment où la
campagne est extrêmement est extrêmement
euh peu peu peu populaire sur la scène
internationale et un moment malgré tout
où il faut qu'elle se poursuive et donc
tout ça est à voir aussi avec les
déclarations récentes de Tsahal qui dit
vouloir passer à une autre phase et
vouloir diminuer l'intensité de ces
frappes ainsi que sa présence de forces
terrestres sur la bande de Gaza alors
vous évoquez la visite du secrétaire
d'État américain on y reviendra dans
dans un instant dans dans ce d'Abas mais
je reste d'abord sur ce premier chapitre
consacré au au traumatisme celui de la
société israélienne mais aussi les
séquelles de cette guerre très
nombreuses côté Palestiniens écoutterz
un témoignage un médecin il est
Britannic palestinien habitué des
territoires en guerre il a passé 43
jours à à Gaza en tant que bénévole il
s'apprête à témoigner auprès de la
police britannique il s'appelle rassan
Abou
Sita chaque jour la moitié des patients
que j'opérais étaient des enfants des
enfants avec des blessures graves et
dévastatrices des blessures qui changent
la
vie soit des amputations soit des
blessures au visage qui défigure
gravement et il ne s'agit là que de
blessures physiques pas de séquel mental
et beaucoup de ces enfants en plus de
leurs blessures avaient perdu leurs
famille leurs parents à un moment donné
nous avons eu à l'hôpital Shifa 120
enfants qui étaient les seuls survivants
de leur famille sur plusieurs
générations qui avaient été blessés et
qui n'avait personne pour s'occuper
d'euxim nan benaken c'est moi j'entends
ça je me dis c'est une génération perdue
combien de ces enfants vont vouloir se
venger dans dans dans quelques
années écoutez oui c'est effectivement
la tragédie qu'on voit C deux sociétés
traumatisées vous allez effectivement
aussi avoir côté palestinien une société
qui a été qui va être bien évidemment
détruite d'une certaine
manière
après en ce qui concerne la la la
société palestinienne et la vengeance
c'est pas quelque chose qui a commencé
malheureusement le 7 octobre
euh vous avez aussi eu malheureusement
depuis des depuis depuis que le Hamas a
pris le pouvoir à Gaza en 2007 une
génération de jeunes qui a été éduqué à
la haine euh et qui à travers les écoles
à travers les médias Palestiniens offici
officiel du ramas a été éduqué à à la
haine donc il va falloir après cette
guerre là après cette destruction
terrible après cette ce nombre me mort
après après cette tragédie il va falloir
re créer tout et dont la partie
éducation qui va être extrêmement
importante où euh où une génération va
devoir apprendre autre chose euh que la
haine la haine de l'autre et l'idée que
les les Juifs pourront peut-être un jour
quitter la terre d'Israël BN vous réagir
oui euh toute construction ou
reconstruction euh passera par la remise
en cause d'un état de faite qui
caractérise ce conflit depuis des
dizaines d'années à savoir une situation
d'occupation et de colonisation donc ce
sont les deux mots clés ce sont deux
mots clés à Gaza ce sont deux mots clés
y compris à Gaza l'occupation militaire
reconnue enendoit internationale
s'agissant de la situation y compris à
Gaza la colonisation de laassis Jordanie
mais si Jordanie est est occupée et
colonisé y compris depuis les accords de
paix d'Oslo euh par les gouvernements
israéliens successessif quelle que soit
la coalition euh même si aujourd'hui le
gouvernement est tout à fait
exceptionnel du point de vue de son
identité politique suprémaciste juif
d'extrême droite qui finalement donneent
le lat de cette politique mais ce qui
est remarquable encore une fois dès
l'ors qu'on essaie de se projeter et
c'est ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'on
narrive pas à identifier euh au sein euh
de du du paysage politique
israélien d'alternative y compris à
cette figure qui aujourd'hui fait
consensus pour ce qui est de sa critique
à savoir Benjamin netanahou mais
malheureusement l'alternative à Benjamin
netanahou n'existe pas personne y
compris dans l'opposition ne remet en
cause la colonisation de la S Jordanie
or encore une fois c'est le point clé de
toute reconstruction du dialogue
politique qui pourrait Infiné aboutir H
uneu qui pourrait enfin qui pourrait
être synonyme d'un État palestinien or
voyez bien lorsquon donne cette parole
pour essayer de construire cet avenir
ces mots sont sont neutralisés ils
sont
invisibilisés c'est tout à fait
significatif c'est une marque de de de
de dénis tout simplement qui dépasse le
le paysage politique et médiatique
israélien lorsqu'on dès lors qu'on
essaie de de parler de la situation oui
le mot occupation vous non non il a il a
bien sûr il a parfaitement raison il y a
la question bien évidemment euh de
laassjordanie euh après je pense que
Gaza la situation est différente je
pense pas qu'on peut complètement euh
euh euh prendre en oublier le fait que
euh le Hamas a pris le pouvoir euh par
un coup d'État euh à Gaza euh et que euh
je les israéliens se sont protégés du
Hamas euh n'ont pas réoccupé euh Gaza
euh et et la réalité c'est que ce que on
a vu le 7 octobre c'est c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles les Israéliens
ont voulu justement se se protéger d'une
organisation terroriste ah je vous
accorde que cela n'a pas fonctionné mais
pour une raison très simple madame c'est
que Benjamin netaniao a soutenu la
montée en puissance du Hamas alors je je
je j'ai beaucoup entendu cet argument on
l'a entendu lui c'est pas j'ai beaucoup
entendu cet
argument il se je pense que la question
du du Hamas à Gaza et et le fait que
j'imagine que vous faites référence au
fait que l'argent du Qatar et a été
donné avec l'accord d'Israël au Hamas
j'imagine c'est c'est que à ça vous vous
faites référence oui pas seulement le
fait qu'il ait toujours sapé l'Autorité
palestinienne pour favoriser le Hamas
tout simplement bon il n'a pas je je il
n'a pas sapé l'Autorité palestinienne en
tant que tel surtout par le fait parce
que le l'Autorité palestinienne aussi il
y a un problème il y a un problème de
corruption il y a un problème par
exemple que aujourd'hui l'Autorité
palestinienne elle-même continue à payer
les familles des terroristes c'est pour
ça qu'il soutient le Hamas non ça veut
ça veut pas dire qu'il soutient le Hamas
il n'a pas soutenu directement le ramas
il a juste permis à l'argent du Qatar à
à à rentrer dans dans Gaza mais il n'a
pas directement soutenu le ramas avec
quoi ben c'est ce qu'il dit hein dans
des vidéos que tout le monde regarde je
vais je vais on va on va avancer dans le
débat on entendu vos argum à l'un et à
l'autre sur ce sur ce thème mais ça ça
rentre dans question pour vous Jérôme cl
sur le l'aide humanitaire parce qu'elle
passe au au comptegoutte finalement ça
rejoint un peu le débat qu'on est en
train d'avoir sur le la place du ramas
et son et son rôle pourquoi l'étatb
est-il aussi strict
euh au risque d'ailleurs de renforcer la
la critique internationale dont vous
parli tout à l'heure sur l'IT renforce
comme vous dites la critique
internationale et de fait on voit bien
que c'est une des composantes sur
laquelle ça les Israël s'assoupl là ces
jours dernier puisque on voit que l'aide
humanitaire passe davantage et c'est le
premier point finalement sur lequel
Anthony blinken va insister sachant que
la réduction des pertes des civiles
c'est quelque chose c'est un vœux pieux
on pourrait revenir pour des raisons
opérationnelles et tactiques euh sachant
aussi que l'escalade on pourrait revenir
c'est quelque chose que l'on maîtrise
qu'à la marge et puis la solution
post-gerre voilà donc le vrai levier
c'est concrètement c'est c'est l'aide
humanitaire en ce que il est hors de
question pour Israël et pour les
États-Unis de fait qui leur accorde un
soutien inconditionnel ouis d'envisager
un cesser le feu et même une trêve
humanitaire donc une trêve pardon qui
consisterait à pouvoir négocier le le le
comment la libération des otages donc le
seul levier c'est finalement c'est
finalement cette aide humanitaire mais
cette aide humanitaire pour Israël ça
représente autant de possibilités de
régénération du Hamas parce que une part
de l'aide humanitaire est détournée par
le Hamas de fait hein que ce soit la
nourriture l'eau le carburant le l'aide
médicale et donc il faut pour elle pour
Israël ménager un compromis entre ce qui
peut entrer et effectivement servir aux
civils de Gaza et ce qui de fait risque
d'être détourné et donc tout aide
humanitaire doit être extrêmement ciblé
et on voit que samedi dernier
typiquement la France et la Jordanie a
effectué un largage de très haute
altitude avec du matériel humanitaire
donc 7 tonnes de matériel humanitaire
sur sur donc un hôpital de campagne Jord
en ça a été autorisé en matière de
survol et ça a été autorisé en matière
de largage par Israël parce qu'il y
avait des garanties opérationnelles et
tactiques que ça irait effectivement à
la destination prévue en une réaction en
cette ce lundi fin d'après-midi celle du
président américain Joe Biden dit je le
cite travailler pour qu'Israël réduise
nettement sa présence à Gaza Julien
Balou comment une telle déclaration du
président américain peut être reçu en en
Israël sur justement la stratégie la
présence
militaire au sein à l'intérieur de la
bande de
Gaza déjà je sais qu'fin comprendre que
on a tous conscience en Israël que les
États-Unis sont entrés en anée
électorale qui c'est une année
importante que le président américain a
besoin de de disons de comment on dit de
de réussite diplomatique pour pour sa
campagne on sait que c'est important et
on le savait en Israël depuis le début
on pensait moi onêement je pensais même
que la pression américaine arrivé bien
plus rapidement que ça mais on savait
que janvier que le tout le passage à
2024 allait être forcément un tournant
et que le le soutien allait devenir un
peu plus compliqué à obtenir de la part
des États-Unis d'autre part sur la
présence dans la bande de Gaza je ne
pense pas révéler un secret en vous
disant que il y a déjà beaucoup moins de
force israëlen dans la bande de Gaza et
j'en veux pour preuve bah déjà le fait
que l'armée israëlnoncit elle-même en
disant avoir libéré certaines certains
certains soldats d'autre part on voit de
plus en plus de soldat revenir du front
terminer leur période de réserve tout à
l'heure je vous parlais donc de ces
personnes qui avaient quitté leur lieu
de travail je peux témoigner moi-même du
fait de voir des collègues revenir au
fur et à mesure au travail donc on est
sur cette dynamique de réduction des
forces israéliennes en en en présence
dans la bande de Gaza euh d'une part
parce que toute la partie nord le
travail militaire a été terminé en
terminé non pas terminé mais en tout cas
bien avancé contre les objectifs du Rama
c'est que maintenant l'essentiel se se
se se concentre au sud mais on parle
beaucoup de la bande de Gaza je peux
vous dire que ce soir on a surtout les
yeux tournés vers la frontière nord
d'Israël parce qu'on en parle très peu à
l'international mais Israël est bombardé
chaque jour depuis le 7 octobre à sa
frontière nord par le resbola depuis le
Liban et ça sent venime ces derniers
jours ça son venim avec donc
l'élimination du chef du ramas dans la B
de beirouth aujourd'hui un chef iranien
également qui a été tué le rebola qui
menace de deiposté euh ça sont venis il
y a un vrai risque d'embrasement là au
nord tout de même alors on y reviendra
dans un instant si vous le voulez bien
je voudrais qu'on consacre un nouveau
chapitre dans ce débat à l'avenir de
Benjamin naniaou d'abord une information
31 décembre manifestation d'opposants
euh au Premier ministre à tel avis on va
dire la première manifestation d'une
telle importance depuis le le 7 octobre
Matthieu est-ce qu'on peut dire que son
avenir politique s'obscurcit mais le
Premier ministre israélien traverse une
des passes les plus difficiles de sa vie
politique commencé il y a 27 ans ce qui
était déjà un parcours pas simplement
mouvementé si je dire mais qui pourrait
peut-être connaître son terme une fois
le conflit achevé jusqu'ici l'homme fort
du Liou était pourtant parvenu à se
relever de toutes les difficultés de
tous les scandales qu'il avait rencontré
mais mais pour Benjamin netaniaahou déjà
politiquement affaibli quand même avant
l'attaque terroriste du 7 octobre les 3
mois qui viennent de se dérouler
ressemble à à une descente petit à petit
aux enfers sa côte de popularité a connu
une chute sans précédent dans l'opinion
publique selon un sondage mené par
l'Institut démocratique israélien par eu
la semaine dernière seulement 15 % des
Israéliens se disent favorable à son
maintien au pouvoir après la guerre je
dis bien après la guerre que lui
reproche-t-il alors le 7 octobre a
marqué on en a beaucoup parlé la
faillite de Monsieur sécurité qui était
la posture qu'il revendiquait depuis des
années alors faudra bien sûr attendre
les conclusions d'une commission
d'enquête qui ne manquera pas de voir le
jour mais on se souvient que après la
guerre du Kipour le travail d'une
commission d'enquête avait coûté son
poste à à Gold la mer mais d'ors et déjà
beaucoup d'Israéliens semblent
sanctionner netaniiaahou de ne pas avoir
su les protéger alors qu'il en avait
fait un de ces thème de prédilection je
l'ai dit les failles sécuritaires euh
que des services ou du mur de Gaza lui
sont aujourd'hui imputé sa gestion du
conflit aussi depuis le 7 octobre se
heurte à de nombreuses critiques alors
je parle de critiqu qui qui qui monte he
c'est pas probablement pas toute la
population israélienne mais euh la
question du sort des otages notamment
hein qui est passé au second plan c'est
quand même une rupture dans l'histoire
de de de de l'histoire euh de l'État
hébreu où ça a toujours été une une
priorité et puis certains quand on
regarde la presse ont parfois du mal à
appréhender le but de guerre la fameuse
éradication du Hamas est-ce que c'est
possible pas possible évidemment un
sentiment général de vouloir en finir
avec l'organisation terroriste mais
est-ce que c'est possible sur le plan
diplomatique ben sur le plan
diplomatique euh Benjamin netaniahou et
je parle de lui-même hein pas forcément
d'Israël et est quand même assez isolé
il y a un signe quand même qui est
étonnant c'est son grand rival benigandz
que Emmanuel Macron a choisi d'appeler
la semaine dernière et non pas lui euh
pour lui faire connaître les inquiétudes
françaises sur le sort de Gaza ou la
volonté qu'il n'y ait pas d'escalade
c'est quand même du jamais vu hein dans
l'histoire de la diplomatie française
qu'un chef de l'État appelle le
responsable desopposition vous imaginez
un peu si c'était l'inverse si quelqu'un
appelait Marine Le Pen ou jeanque
Mélenchon euh comment la France
réagirait évidemment quelques infos sur
ce on va dire le la situation les
raisons de politique intérieure
également oui ben alors le le 1er
janvier la Cour suprême israélienne a
rejeté un des volets de la fameuse vous
savez réforme judiciaire qui était très
contestée et qui avait profondément
divisé les Israéliens en décembre
dernier après 2 mois de suspension le
procès pour corruption de Beniamin
netaniiaou a repris alors bien sûr
disons-le Beniamin netaniahou dispose
toujours d'une majorité jugée stable à
la cisset et que très peu d'observateurs
voient basculer avant la fin du conflit
personne ne la voit basculer c'est
d'ailleurs d'une certaine façon tout le
paradoxe de sa situation personnelle à
Ben netaniaahou dont le sort politique
est d'une certaine façon lié à la
poursuite de cette guerre contre le
Hamas ce qui ce qu' inaugure pardon
évidemment rien de bon pour tous les
Israéliens qui sont partisans d'un pays
enfin pacifié Simon Ron Benzaken le
soutien de la population israélienne à à
néania est-ce qu'on le voit quand même
s'éroder petit à petit oui oui
clairement je crois que hier il y a eu
un sondage qui est sorti qui clairement
démontre que netaniao baisse très
largement dans les sondages la
personnalité politique qui ressort le
plus c'est benigansz qui fait qui
aujourd'hui a s'il y avait des élection
aujourd'hui serait à 33 sièges et donc
pourraelle largement créer une coalition
gouvernable donc c'est un responsable
politique plutôt centre centriste qui
fait partie du cabinet de guerre et oui
clairement beaucoup beaucoup de
questions il y a aussi le fait que vous
avez quasiment vous avez toutes les
semaines des manifestations en Israël
euh à la notamment la place des otages
où auparavant il y avait des
manifestations contre la réforme de la
justice toutes les semaines des
manifestations il y a quelques jours des
manifest estation devant la maison de de
benamin netanaho à Césaria donc oui vous
avez effectivement plus de plus de
concensation au sein de la population
israen contestation de benamin N
monsieur sécurité mais est-ce qu'il y a
une alternative pour une autre politique
alors vous l'avez un peu évoqué tout à
l'heure mais je vous entendre làdessus
si on s'entient vraiment la vie
politique israélo israélienne si je dire
c'est une vie démocratiquement riche où
benamin N est poursuivi pour corruption
donc ce qui atteste plutôt d'une vigueur
judiciaire d'une séparation des pouvoirs
euh avec vraiment une un débat
contradictoire y compris sur des
questions plus classiques hein d'ordre
économique et social parce que c'est
l'un des angles d'attaque contre
Benjamin netaniao aussi euh donc c'est
une démocratie au sans en qui c'est un
régime qui apparaît comme démocratique
de ce point de vue-là par contre moi du
point de vue du conflit
israëlo-palestinien le le débat c'est
affaibli de plus en plus pauvre en ce
sens où les alternatives n'apparaissent
plus véritablement on a cité vous avez
cité monsieur gandz comme figure
alternative ou de l'opposition il a été
questionné sur la la question de la
colonisation de laassile Jordanie il y a
encore quelques semaines il a répondu
très clairement de manière très univoque
qu'il ne remettait pas en cause la
politique de colonisation et il s'est
référé non pas au droit international
mais à la Bible c'est dire que on
retrouve ce qui peut nous choquer dans
la bouche de l'extrême droite
israélienne aujourd'hui à savoir
finalement une forme de rationalité qui
nous parle pas des démocrates mais qui
en réalité se diffuse largement au-delà
de ce qu'on appelle l'extrême droite dès
lors qu'on parle d'une solution à ce
conflit oui juste côté palestinien il y
a pas de démocratie puisqu'on sait qu'il
y a pas d'élections qui ont été
organisées depuis plus de dizaine
d'années est-ce qu'il y a des figures
qui sont capables d'incarner une
alternative plutôt propa ou on cherche
les messagers de paix des deux côtés
quoi h oui là c'est là aussi il y a le
baabess également mais de manière encore
enfin plus visible encore d'une certaine
manière dans la mesure où l'autorité
palestinienne est délégitimée du point
de vue démocratique puisquil na Mahmoud
Abbas n'a son mandat a expiré depuis pas
mal d'années déjà et surtout il n'a plus
d'assise populaire il il n'a plus de
légitimité populaire ou au-delà même de
sa légitimité institutionnelle euh et à
Gaza même chose le Hamas n'a pas permis
l'organisation d'élection libre et
pluraliste et plus largement les deux
principal force palestiniennes n'ont pas
réussi à s'accorder pour organiser un
scrutin digne de ce nom et puis il y a
des figures mais dès lors qu'elles
apparaissent soit ces deux parties
tentent de les neutraliser si elles ne
correspondent pas à leur à leur AX soit
côté israélien aussi il y a cette
politique qui consiste à emprisonner des
des acteurs po tique palestinien qui
pourrait représenter à un moment donné
une solution
politiquezy si je peux juste me
permettre il y a notamment depuis le 7
octobre et ce qui fait par ailleurs que
une partie de la l'opinion politique une
opinion israélienne se durcit c'est que
vous n'avez aucun responsable
palestinien qui a condamné les les
attentats les attaques du 7 octobre et
au contraire vous avez dans les discours
Palestiniens y compris dans l'autorité
palestinenne je vais vous citer dibril
rajou par exemple secrétaire du comité
central du Fatar le 17 décembre nous
voyons l'islam politique et notamment le
Hamas comme une partie intégrante de
notre lutte nous devons préserver nos
acquis nous sommes un projet de
libération et nous sommes tous des
martyres en puissance donc quand vous
avez ce genre de discours je il y a
aussi bien évidemment des discours très
problématiques côté israélien mais quand
vous avez ce genre de discours que vous
entendez forcément côté israélien le
public israélien se durcit et
effectivement n'y croit plus quand vous
allez vous avez parlé tout à l'heure de
karaza j'étais donc à karaza j'étais
aussi à
bairieib son gens qui qui sont
l'incarnation de la de la gauche presque
disparue en Israël des gens qui
croyaient à la coexistence avec les
Palestiniens qui envoyé des messages de
Pai et C aujourd'hui vous leur posez la
question qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire ils
ont perdu tout espoir ils n'y croyaient
plus ils sont convaincus que les
palestiniensès v vous êtes intervenu
longuement juste avant très vite très
vite toujours pour rappeler que
justement si Mahmoud Abbas avait été
soutenu par la communauté internationale
au début de son mandat c'était
précisément parce qu'il optait
strictement pour un discours pacifique
et pour une solution diplomatique or il
n'a jamais été soutenu par son
interlocuteur quel qu'il soit
israélien problème Julien Balou voulez
intervenir vous voulez répondre même à B
nabl allez-y oui absolument en fait je
dire deux choses sur marabas je va pas
mettre sur marabas il a donc été élu en
janvier 2005 pour un mandat de 4 ou 5
ans en 2024 chacun fera le calcul il n'a
pas organisé d'élection présidentielle
depuis ensuite il est faux de dire qu'il
n'a pas été soutenu j'ai ce beau
souvenir je cette date en tête du 8
février 2005 à chelcher en Égypte avec
Charon qui sert la main de marabas c'est
les deux qui s'engagent ensemble vers
des négociations suivi de oudol mert
également suivi de netanou qui fait le
discours de baryan en 2009 où il
s'engage un État palestinien et cetera
et cetera donc il est faux de dire que
marcoabas n'a pas été soutenu ensuite
d'un point de vue donc je va pas méiser
sur la sur la politique palestinenne il
y a pas de scène politique palestinenne
vu qu' a pas de démocratie palestinienne
et qu' a pas de figure de de du camp de
la paix palestinien il n'existe pas
enanche sur le côté israëlien moi je
vote à gauche donc je je j'en parle avec
je su très à l'aise j'ai manifesté
contreo pendant 9 mois donc on peut pas
me soupçonner d'un quelconque soutien au
gouvernement actuel ce que je veux dire
c'est que c'est vrai que vous avez dit
tout à l'heure Benny Gans donc a répondu
avec des arguments bibliques bon qui
sont les siens sur laass Jordanie je
crois que au-delà de de cet attachement
biblique ce qu'il y a c'est que si vous
posez des questions la question à
quelqu'un comme moi par exemple ou à des
habitant de farazard comme le disait
Simon tout à l'heure et si on nous
demande est-ce que vous êtes pour un
retrait des territoires on va réfléchir
deux fois avant de dire oui parce que on
a soutenu le retrait israélien de la
bande de Gaza en 2005 en espérant que ça
apporte la paix et il y avait pas de
blocus israélien au début sur la bande
de gaz en 2005 marouabas est venu j'ai
des souvenirs de lui qui efface les tags
sur les murs pour enlever les les traces
les souvenirs de l'occupation et un an
après le Hamas est élu par les
Palestiniens et un an après encore en
juin 2007 il y a le coup d'État du Hamas
qui prend de force la la la bande de
Gaza et aujourd'hui on on on s'est
retiré dans la bande de Gaza aujourd'hui
on a eu un pogrom le 7 octobre et on a
des missiles qui r visit jusqu'à ma
maison il y a encore même pas une heure
on avait des explosion dehors parce que
sur la band laabive il y a des missiles
pour ti il encore il y a encore à peine
une heure j'ai mis les chaussures de mes
fill à l'entrée pour descendre si vous
voulez qu'on se retire de C Jordani mais
si c'est pour avoir le même résultat en
fait on va tous mourir bon allez je il
nous reste le temps àiler merci Julien
Balou il nous reste moins de 10 minutes
et il y a un thème dont il faut
absolument parler parce que c'est
évidemment l'actualité qui concerne la
justice internationale et je vais
proposer à Steve jourain de nous
rejoindre tout de suite re bonsoir Steve
bienvenue une nouvelle fois sur ce
plateau la la justice internationale qui
cette semaine s'intéresse au conflit
entre Israël et le ramas oui et Israël
est sur le banc des accusés dès ce jeudi
vous l'avez dit Thomas la justice
internationale se penche sur la guerre
en cours dans la bande de Gaza fin
décembre c'est l'Afrique du Sud qui a
déposé une requête contre l'État hébreu
elle l'accuse et bien de de perpétrer un
génocide contre le peuple palestinien
dans l'enclave c'est un gros document un
document de de 84 pages qui a été envoyé
à la Cour internationale de justice on
peut y lire la chose suivante les
actions et omissions d'Israël sont
génocidaires dans leur nature car elle
cherche à détruire une partie
substantielle du groupe ethnique racial
et national palestinien fin de citation
Prétoria demande également l'arrêt
immédiat des combats à Gaza et la mise
en place d'un cess le feu durable que
risque Israël c'est quoi cette Cour
internationale de justice benah c'est
l'instance judiciaire la plus haute des
nations- Unies elle a été créée après la
deuxième guerre mondiale pour
les conflits entre États alors faut pas
confondre avec la CPI un cour pénal
international qui elle ne s'intéresse
qu'aux individus et juge les responsaes
soupçonnés de crimes de guerre les deux
cours siègent au Pays-Bas la Cour
internationale de justice elle traite
des contentieux entre état par exemple
en cas de différents autour des
frontières ou en cas de violation de
traités internationaux comment va se
dérouler ce procès alors la israël va se
défendre contre les accusations de de
génocide la ligne est claire si crime il
y a ils sont du côté du Hamas écouter le
Premier ministre
israélien je voudrais dire un mot sur la
fausse accusation de l'Afrique du Sud
selon laquelle Israël commet un génocide
à Gaza non ce n'est pas nous qui sommes
venus commettre un génocide c'est le
Hamas il nous tuerait tous s'il le
pouvait en revanche les forces
d'israéliennes agissent de la manière la
plus morale qui soit elles font tout
pour éviter de blesser des civils tandis
que le Hamas fait tout pour mettre en
danger les civils palestiniens en les
utilisant comme bouclier
humain
voilà pour appuyer cet argument il
serait le compte diffusé au juges des
images du massacre du 7 octobre des
images qui ont jusque là été diffusé
seulement aux journalistes au
responsables politiques au responsables
diplomatiques qui sont ceux qui vont
trancher cette affaire alors la la cour
est composée de 15 juges à cela il faut
ajouter deux magistrats supplémentaires
choisis par les partis en présence côté
israelen petite surprise c'est l'ancien
juge Aaron Barac qui a été choisi par
Benjamin netanou c'est pas n'importe qui
c'est l'une et bien des grandes figures
de l'opposition libérale on peut pas le
le soupçonner de rouler pour le Premier
ministre israélien il a 87 ans il est à
l'origine d'importante réforme du
système juridique en Israël c'est aussi
un rescapé de la Choa et ça pourrait
compter dans l'argumentaire qu'il compte
déployer devant les juges la procédure
pourrait s'étendre sur plusieurs années
avant un éventuel verdict final mais dès
cette semaine les juges pourraient
ordonner à Israël de suspendre ses
opérations militaires à Gaza les
décisions de la Cour sont juridiquement
contraignantes mais Israël ne si Israël
ne veut pas les respecter Israël ne les
respectera pas pour une raison simple
c'est que la Cour n'a aucun pouvoir
cooherceétif ce qui est surtout en jeu
Thomas dans cette affaire c'est du
symbole et du rapport de force
diplomatique merci beaucoup Steve
Jourdain pour toutes ces informations B
nabl on va pas avoir le temps de parler
de la raison pour laquelle l'Afrique du
Sud est derrière cette requête mais je
suis sûr qu'on fera d'autres débats et
que vous nous l'expliquerez une autre
fois mais mais quand même il faut qu'on
prenne un peu de temps pas assez à mon
goût mais voilà sur ce ce terme génocide
qui est qui est présent dans la dans la
requête comment le le qualifier
évidemment il est lourd de sens bon déjà
votre notre ami votre collègue très bien
fait son travail il a rappelé les
éléments essentiel de cette affaire en
rappelant notamment ce la définition du
génocide qui est très chargé du point de
vue symbolique et historique donc d'où
notre notre enfin la prudence qui
s'impose en la matière sauf qu'en enroit
il y a quand même des définitions qui
existe y compris pour ce mot très chargé
symboliquement et il existe même une
convention spéciale vous avez la
Convention sur le génocide de 1948 et
puis vous avez aussi une définition sur
le génocide consacré par les statuts de
la CPI et qui identifie les mêmes
éléments premièrement le fait qu'il y
ait des des crimes qui soient perpétrés
et deuxièmement surtout je dirais que
ces crimes traduisent l'intention de
détruire un groupe un groupe national du
fait de sa race de son ethnie bref la
volonté de détruire un groupe et donc
tout tout l'enjeu c'est de faire la
démonstration de cette volonté de cette
volonté politique ça sera je pense ce
qui sera au cœur de des pldoiries des
deux parties et côté sud-africain j'ai
j'ai eu le temps de regarder le dossier
bon ils ont naturellement constitué un
dossier solide au sens où il y a des
arguments de fait et de droit euh après
il y a un débat contradictoire qui va
naturellement se développer devant la
Cour internationale de justice mais ce
qui est très important c'est le retour
du droit dans un conflit où précisément
le droit est neutralisé
ouol et ne pas respecter sa lettre
SIM ce terme je reprends que nous disait
Steve les termes de la requête
sudafricaine une partie substantielle du
groupe ethnique racial et national
palestinien Israël veut-elle détruire
cette partie substantielle comment vous
réagissez à ce à l'emploi de ce mot
c'est
forcémentot qui qui est extrêmement
chargé il y a la question il a très
justement dit politique et d'autant plus
pour Israël ou bien
évidemment Israël le peuple juif a vécu
un génocide et donc c'est forcément
extrêmement chargé de sens je je pense
que encore une fois le procès va durer
longtemps ça sera
l'opportunité pour Israël aussi euh de
d'expliquer ce que ce que cette guerre
là que le ce qu'elle a essayé de faire
pendant pendant des années et peut-être
c'est pas pas si mal que ça parce que
beaucoup se fait effectivement sur les
médias dans les médias des des des
arguments des contreargumentss là il y a
le droit qui va parler Israël aura
l'opportunité d'exposer ses arguments et
c'est c'est peut-être une bonne
opportunité Jér à vous le mot de la
conclusion oui je je crois quand même
aussi qu'il faudra regarder sur pièce ce
qui s c'est produit c'est-à-dire en
matière de ciblage concrètement de quoi
parle-ton comment Israël a établi ses
cartes de ciblage concrètement c'est
1800 killbx avec des zones très
identifiées une aide avec l'intelligence
artificielle pour identifier les cibles
l'intelligence artificielle a fourni des
centaines de cibles ça a été fait par la
machine supervisé par l'homme mais par
la machine de façon à un maximiser le
nombre de terroristes rabattu et de
minimiser le nombre de pertes civiles ce
qui veut dire qu'au sein d'un immeuble
et au sein d'une pièce typiquement s'il
y avait un terroriste et sa famille il
était potentiellement frappé d'où les
victimes collatérales civiles mais s'il
y avait un immeuble sans terroriste avec
que des civils il n'était pas frappé
donc l'intention qui vise à
finalement éradiquer toute une ethnie
elle est clairement pas matérialisée
dans le ciblage tout ce sera l'une des
questions que question et c'est ça qui
sera examiné concrètement pour savoir si
effectivement il y a eu cette intention
ou pas est-ce qui il y a dommage
collatéral regrettable et toujours
regrettable et toujours à minimiser où
est-ce qu'il y a eu cette intention
effectivement de crime de génocide et
c'est là que ça pourra se discriminer
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat j'ai rapidement
appelé les titres de vos livres B Nabli
relations internationales droit théorie
et pratique c'est aux édition pédon et
Jérôme clche la prospective stratégique
chez Herman voilà merci à toutes et à
tous de votre fidélité je vous dis à
demain 18h et 22h sur Public Sénat d'ici
là belle soirée sur les chaînes
parlementaires